les sécurités alimentaires existent ici
c'est le quotidien de 84% des Inuits
mais grâce à leur culture bien vivante
leur spiritualité et leur fierté des
solutions existent et ce sont des
petites victoires au quotidien c'est ce
qu'on vous présente aujourd'hui avec
cette émission spéciale
il peut un peu brouillard il fait froid
il fait beau on va aller essayer
Charline okawak a œuvré toute sa vie à
la préservation de la culture et des
traditions de son peuple il agit
aujourd'hui comme guide avec son
collègue Hippo pour une excursion de
chasse sur la banquise de la baie du son
près des nouglets
[Applaudissements]
on mange beaucoup encore la nourriture
qu'on cherche mais on mange beaucoup
aussi les gens les déchets
mais de plus en plus on voit les gens
qui mangent juste les affaires qu'on
achète au magasin ça c'est triste
la nourriture de la du système
traditionnel des épiceries devient
essentiels c'est pas comment cuisiner
préparer ta nourriture mais tu as pas le
choix d'acheter ce qui est déjà tout
fait puisqu'il est déjà tout fait coûte
un prix exorbitant
dans le village d'une jouarreque le coût
de la vie est très élevé pour les
quelques 2000 habitants à l'épicerie on
est vite constaté que les produits
transformés coûtent effectivement une
fortune mais pour les aliments frais
quand ils sont disponibles c'est une
autre histoire deux joueurs en
alimentation se font compétition dans le
Grand Nord la note ou est-ce compagnie
qui opère 9 magasins généraux au
numérique en plus de ses 120 autres dans
les régions éloignées du Nord canadien
et il y a les 14 coopératives regroupés
sous une fédération
tout ce que les gens veulent on l'envoie
à l'exception des véhicules c'est trop
gros pour rentrer dans un intermédiaire
on parle de tout des meubles à la pierre
tombale aux légumes Daniel Lelièvre gère
la provisionnement depuis Montréal à la
Fédération des coopératives du nouveau
Québec il est à même de voir ce qui sera
abordable pour les consommateurs une
fois acheminés avec les façons de
travailler et des subventions nutritions
en or cela nous aide beaucoup on peut
obtenir un prix de vente raisonnable et
puis depuis des années la coopérative
met un en phase sur les fruits et
légumes elle réduit son profit elle-même
à la base la perception que ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher dans le Nord
parce que on a vu plein d'aliments de
base qui était sensiblement au même prix
on a vu des choses très très cher par
exemple ce n'est pas la structure de
prix c'est souvent chez nous pas assis
de l'or le kilo si vous envoyez quelque
chose qui pèse 1 kg vous avez 6 dollars
de transport sur le coût du produit
[Musique]
le gouvernement fédéral vers cette année
plus de 130 millions de dollars pour
permettre aux Inuits d'avoir accès à des
aliments sains à prix abordables par
l'entremise de son programme nutrition
Nord Canada
c'est une subvention pour réduire le
coût de transport quelle sorte
d'alimentation subventionnés les fruits
légumes certains produits congelés le
lait des portes alimentaires un peu de
tout
ça
veut dire que nutrition
de 4 dollars et 51 pour se produire en
particulier
[Musique]
scène de réduction grâce au programme
provincial cost of living géré par le
gouvernement régional cativique en plus
des dividendes de la cooping
avec les subventions il y a des aliments
qui co sensiblement la même chose que
dans le sud de la province il y a des
prix par contre qui nous ont fait
dépriser mais là où le bobelet surtout
c'est dans la qualité et l'offre des
produits frais je vous dirai qu'il y a
toujours des creux dans la semaine qui
ont des arrivages ont envie qu'on cible
nos journées les arrivages quand tu
arrives on sait de telle journée allez-y
c'est le temps il y a plein de fruits et
légumes avec ça c'est l'hiver c'est une
longue période
effectivement c'est difficile le
transport c'est cela en jeu du Nord
la Fédération des coopératives envoie
via
Hérin 8 l'équivalent de 7 camions
semi-remorque par semaine afin de
réduire les coûts du transport aérien la
cargaison peut aussi transiter par la
route vers la grande avant de s'envoler
vers les communautés comme inoud ce
voyage peut grandement abîmer les
aliments surtout lorsque Dame Nature ne
collabore pas et que les avions sont
cloués au sol quelques jours depuis
notre dernière visite de toute évidence
il y a eu une livraison de fruits il y a
des bananes des oranges quelque part
mais si les gens dis-nous de joie qui
avaient envie de cuisiner des légumes il
y a plus de pommes de terre il ne reste
que quelques carottes et des salades
président au développement économique de
Makivik une société à bu non lucratif
propriétaire de RN8 et qui veille aux
intérêts des résidents du numérique
les investissements et les subventions
sont au rendez-vous mais les critiques
fusent tout de même la gestion du
programme nutrition Nord préoccupe des
leaders inwi il faut dire que dès 2014
le vérificateur général du Canada avait
demandé plus de lumière sur la gestion
de ce compte aujourd'hui la députée
néodémocrate du Nunavut l'origland
craint que les consommateurs ne soient
pas ceux qui profitent le plus de ces
subventions dans notre chaîne
[Musique]
le ministre des affaires du Nord d'Anne
Vandal se défend de ce manque de
transparence c'est un bon programme
c'est pas parfait et on cherche toujours
des méthodes de
améliorer une nutrition Nord incluant
comme des programmes comme souvent sur
les chasseurs ça fait que j'ai confiance
que nous trouvions c'est un bon
programme qui profite Paul et privé ou
deux ans une grosse audition qui
viennent ici puis mensuellement on fait
des rapports des auditeurs qui nous
vérifient qui nous posent des questions
le gouvernement vers soucis 120 millions
sur deux ans pour soutenir les chasseurs
et les pêcheurs et de nouveaux accords
permettent désormais aux organisations
et gouvernement régionaux de distribuer
ses fonds aux communautés admissibles
comme le souhaite l'ex-maire de coup de
joie
du gouvernement c'est vraiment donner
une opportunité aux Inuits nous n'avez
de prendre le lait de ce pour prendre
l'édition sortir des programmes c'est
nous qui connaît très bien notre réalité
notre environnement comment les animaux
en fonction
comme les gens dans le sud ils reçoivent
des subventions pour les agriculteurs
pour produire la nourriture pour au
public général on chasse on est des
chasseurs puis on se rendent des
subventions aussi équivalent mais c'est
toujours passé
[Musique]